im grunde können wir beim thema bleiben
2018 geht zu ende das letzte jahr in dem
diesel fahren in deutschland legal ist
ja bald kommen die fahrverbote nach dem
urteil gestern vielleicht auch für euro
6 diesel noch einmal glückwunsch an alle
die sich in die sogenannte
umtauschaktion haben einlagern lassen
von unserem lieben verkehrsminister an
die scheuer ja gutermann guter mann
passend dazu hat die cdu gerade auf
ihrem parteitag beschlossen der
deutschen umwelthilfe die
gemeinnützigkeit zu entziehen weil der
neue verein ständig vor gericht zieht
diese gruppe hat nicht die eier sich mit
der autoindustrie anzulegen aber
schimpft auf durchgeknallte richter die
es wagen geltendes recht anzuwenden
hinter der attacke auf die umwelthilfe
steckt übrigens die cdu nordwürttemberg
wo besonders viele autofirmen ihren sitz
haben bestimmt zu fall
ich will einfach nur wissen wie viel
spenden sie bekommen von der rettung
biete sie müssen es ja auch ausweisen
also können sie es mir sie haben sich in
unserem rechenschaftsbericht
nachgeschaut oder was steht nichts drin
ja also das heißt sie bekommen keine
spenden nichts geht über ein natürliches
lachen meine damen und herren wir haben
nachgezählt 6,3 millionen hat die cdu
seit 2009 von der autoindustrie erhalten
sie wecke das war verdammt gut
angelegtes geld wenn man bedenkt wie
deutsche autofirmen den usa behandelt
werden wie kriminelle immer das echte
opfer ist doch der mensch und zwar der
mensch an die scheuer unser an die sein
ministerium ist die mutter aller haas
kam ja der animus ja nicht nur täglich
das mir den fahrverboten verborgen er
muss auch das mit der deutschen bahn
verbocken und das mit den funkel ja ja
und für letzteres gibt es heute den
digitalisierungs vollpfosten in der
nokia edition ja ja
die älteren erinnern sich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nochmal so garantiert kein empfang aber
wussten ja dass alles liebt der andi und
nach feierabend verdient dass ich sogar
noch was dazu als dj rußfiltern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bach de c die kinder man kann auch ohne
alkohol kein spaß haben lieber andreas
wir sagen glückwunsch partie und hier
ist dein lied
ich hoffe dass bratsche und anschließend
als verkehrsminister bring ich komme und
leid und über den diesel weiß es nicht
bescheid wenn ich bin der scheuer ich
kann echt nichts
und sneakers bringe ich die red wings
das ist bescheuert
ich finde mich trotzdem geil
so ist es
und wir tragen
es ist egal was du an
[Musik]
nein
das machen
als ob du
[Musik]
[Applaus]